of all of the perplexing questions in
politics and there are a lot of them
sometimes the the libs do things that we
don't expect them to do the
conservatives do things we say why are
you doing that why aren't you doing this
it does politics seems to get more and
more confusing each day but the one
issue that i know a lot of us are
scratching our heads on is
why
are the libs
spending so much time and money
trying to push weird sex stuff on little
kids they are they're pushing
the transgender agenda they're pushing
pornography in elementary school
libraries they're pushing all sorts of
creepy weird sex stuff with kids and
people come up with all of these deep
profound esoteric answers there's one
man who's given an answer that went
completely viral it seems to be the most
persuasive one
that is oren mcintyre he's a columnist
recovering journalist youtuber and he
said hey guys
it's not that complicated they're just
perverts and they want to diddle kids or
and thank you for coming on the show
oh no yeah thank you so much for having
me i appreciate it
before we get into your answer on that
question why do you think that that
tweet went viral
yeah it was pretty wild i you know you
make a meme and you just put it out
there you don't really expect it to kind
of do what it did but i think it's
because it kind of spoke to a truth that
a lot of us felt and but we didn't say
out loud it wasn't
really couched in a lot of you know
academic language it didn't sound very
high brow and educated but it broke
through a lot of those kind of different
layers of abstraction and just kind of
said the obvious and people are so kind
of hesitant to do that today that i
think it just kind of spoke to something
everybody wanted to say but but hadn't i
think that tweet might have been the
first time i was introduced to you and
your work and so i said i gotta follow
this guy he's really really cutting
through all the as you say the jargon
and all of that nonsense and one thing
that i have really enjoyed from your
writing that i've tried to do myself is
you don't only take pot shots at the
libs you you reserve a lot of your ire
for conservatives and squishes and all
that sort of thing who uh
in many ways seem to be nothing more
than the court jesters in the kingdom of
liberalism that that our political
problems
maybe run a little bit deeper than just
republican versus democrat
yeah when we look at what's going on
it's really easy to get trapped into the
frame that's handed to us by the media
and even our conservative media right
and so when we look at that it's very
easy to focus on the day-to-day issues
and policy decisions and not ask
questions about the wider you know
political scenario why do the teams line
up the way they do why are we so
invested in these particular political
battle lines were there any other points
in history where right and left looked
different what are kind of the core
things that something like say
conservatism is actually conserving
because if we look at it it doesn't seem
like very much and so kind of as we look
a little below the surface i think that
that's kind of where so some of my stuff
breaks through is
we can get outside of that mainstream
frame and maybe you know explore some of
those areas and ask are these opinions
something that organic that makes sense
with our worldview our religion our our
morality
or is it something that's been handed to
us and we're defending because we've
been told that's the team we're on and i
think that's something that makes a big
difference and then when someone hands
you the framework that you're supposed
to play in very often you end up in a
situation where it's heads i win tails
you lose and and there's really no way
that you can have a victory even these
terms left and right
they they refer to the french revolution
they refer to the national assembly and
so
maybe there's more in our political
order and i guess donald trump really
brought a lot of this to the surface in
2016
where all of a sudden you had a lot of
people who had said they were
republicans i mean the bush family for
goodness sakes uh lining up against the
republican nominee at that convention
it was only bob dole was the only living
republican nominee for president who
actually showed up to the convention for
trump
you had a lot of conservatives saying no
i hate trump on tariffs i hate him on
trade i hate him on immigration i don't
agree with this guy on anything if this
is what it means to be a republican if
this is what it means to be conservative
i guess i'm not that and there's been a
whole lot of soul searching that's gone
on what does it mean to be a
conservative what does it mean to be a
republican what so i i guess then i i
just ask you
as we're all trying to figure this out
what should conservatives be conserving
well and that's a really difficult
question because i think that
requires conservatives to look at kind
of the core
of their ideology that they've been
invested in defending for so long the
core of american conservatism is largely
classical liberalism and classical
liberalism on boards a lot of
assumptions that kind of lead it to lose
against the more radical versions of
liberalism that are now kind of in vogue
in kind of our ruling class and so
because conservatives are always in a
mindset of say for instance small
government at any cost they they tie
their own hands when it comes to
implementing agendas that will benefit
the family benefit religious
conservatives benefit other people who
are part of their coalition and so that
that's something that conservatives
really need to do some soul searching on
you know patrick deneen has a book
called why liberalism failed and for
those who haven't read it and are kind
of interested in it i think it's a
really good place to start because
patrick didn't explain that liberalism
has been cracked and spread kind of over
the two parties the democrats got the
social version of liberalism and the
republicans got the economic version of
liberalism and you'll notice that
whenever the republicans are in power
the only thing that gets passed is tax
cuts and when the left is in power for
some reason none of that redistributive
justice or those free college trips
actually get passed it's all the crazy
social stuff that gets pushed it's
always these versions these halves of
liberalism that are always being pushed
forward and so that's why you end up in
that game like you were talking about
heads i win tails you lose so i guess
one of the assumptions that both the
left and the right tend to focus on and
begin with in in america at least these
days is that the basic unit of society
is the individual and and you see it
play out just as you're describing the
individual gets to stop pretty much
whoever he wants to and gets to engage
in whatever
personal behaviors he wants to and uh
for the for the conservatives they say
well the individual should be able to
keep all of his own money
and make all of his own choices about
his personal life you can do whatever
you want just don't just don't make me
pay for it sort of thing and
when i when i look at that assumption
i i say wait a second this isn't that's
that's not conservative at all edmund
burke you know one of the considered one
of the founders of modern conservative
philosophy and many of the founding
fathers for that matter would be rolling
in their graves at that assumption
because it seems to me that the basic
unit of society is the family you
remember when conservatives used to talk
about the family now we haven't
conserved the definition of the family
and we're using all the same kind of
individualist language that the libs use
how do we get back to a kind of
family-oriented i don't know traditional
sort of political framework in america
well that's the trick right power always
wants to centralize it always wants to
take away power from the periphery and
centralize it under its control and so
what's been very powerful
for government has been the narrative of
the individual because what that has
done is allowed people to liberate
people from what used to be these
competing social spheres of obligation
we used to all be part of families and
churches and civic organizations and
guilds and unions and different things
that demanded our loyalty and our money
and our time but over the years those
different intermediate organizations
have dissolved themselves those bonds
that used to bring communities together
and hold them together without the
interference of the government have been
removed and in their place the
government has stepped in as kind of a
weak counterpart right that's part of
the welfare state but it's also part of
so many other things that the government
has involved itself in it always comes
with a pro with a promise of liberation
for the individual right why do we have
to involve the government here to
guarantee your right to something else
right your freedom in some other area
and so by dissolving those bonds the
government has been able to take on more
and more centralized power sometimes
under the idea of collectivism sometimes
under the idea of individualism but it's
always in the service of breaking down
those institutions that were competing
with the government and centralizing the
power back with the state that's such a
great point i sometimes think if karl
marx were alive today mercifully he is
not he's looking up at us right now and
watching us conduct this interview but
if marx were alive today i sort of think
he wouldn't be a democrat i think he
would be in the tea party or something i
think he would probably describe himself
as a radical individualist i mean when
you when you talk to radicals on the
left they very frequently use the
language of individualism in much the
same way as you might hear someone
on the american right use use that kind
of language but you think of the image
of fascism the image of fascism is what
a a big bundle of sticks all brought
together well you can only bring the big
bundle of sticks together when the
sticks have been broken out of all those
associations the family the community
the churches once they've been broken
out of all of those structures and then
they're just alone as individuals then
you bind them up together in
the collective of the state or
you see it on the left in communism and
you see so
it seems to be one of those two sides of
the same coin kind of issue that the
opposite of collectivism
is not
individualism those two actually kind of
seem to help each other it's
it's the family and the churches and all
those intermediate institutions so the
word you use there at the very top is is
an important one you said
power
that power is kind of flowing between
these institutions
that's a naughty word for a lot of
american conservatives we don't like the
idea of power we want to back away from
power we want to look you just
take the power back i don't want to run
your life you don't want to run my life
let's just let it go
you're saying that doesn't really work
yeah that's right a lot of you know one
of the ideas of conservatism because
it's taken this libertarian bin is the
idea that they can take this power right
they can take the ring of power and they
can throw it into mount doom you can
destroy the power and then no one has to
deal with its consequences but that's
not actually how
power works sovereignty can never be
destroyed it's always conserved it can
simply just be handed from one to
another it has to be invested in
something right and so american
conservatives we like to believe that
the constitution allows us to basically
avoid being ruled because the
constitution is this delicate balance of
you know checks and balances and
separation of powers monoskew and and
all this stuff allows us to basically
keep the government under control we're
under the rule of law and so because
we're under the rule of law we don't
have to worry about kind of the people
who are in control of our system because
we don't actually serve them we're not
actually under them we rule ourselves
and this kind of objective system
operates in the background and makes
sure that everything is fair right but
as we're seeing very often today it's
becoming increasingly clear no one is
ever actually governed just by a system
we're governed by people laws are really
powerless to constrain
the actions of an organized minority of
people who want to subvert them as long
as those people are operating in the
correct institutions and positions of
power inside the american government i
think that we're seeing maybe even the
left see that a little bit with the
supreme court here recently right you
see them suddenly losing their minds
because they have to deal with the same
kind of phenomenon that american
conservatives have dealt with for many
many decades that a small minority can
basically
change on a dime what has been kind of
the reality inside the united states and
so conservatives have to be more
comfortable with the idea of power in
the use of it because if they're not
yeah i have another tweet that's kind of
go goes around you know the team that
wants to win always beats the people who
just want to be left alone right and
that's what who conservatives are they
just want to grill man they just want to
go out and enjoy fourth of july they got
the kids they got the business they got
the beautiful home they've got things to
do they don't have time to like you know
be become professional activists and and
you know scream at the heavens every
time something happens
but that is not a good tactic the the
people who want it are going to win and
you can never live in this kind of
fantasy where the government is just
going to leave you alone in perpetuity
you have to invest every every
generation has to care about the values
that are being inculcated and the and
the things that are then being passed
into law and carried forward you don't
just get to kind of put the government
on autopilot and let it protect your
rights once you set up the system
correctly unfortunately we never escape
the rule of men and we have to then
generate good leaders and put them in
positions that will defend our values
and our families we can't just hand it
over the constitution and hope it does
the job all by itself but we are at this
dispositional disadvantage here that
you've totally hit on correctly which is
as conservatives you'll sometimes see
these social scientific surveys go
around they say conservatives are hotter
than leftists or something like that
conservatives are happier than leftists
and whenever i see those i always think
yeah duh we're we're pretty content with
the way things are yeah we like our
lives we like our families we're not we
don't dye our hair crazy colors and put
in all sorts of mutilations and go
screaming and shrieking in front of
government buildings all the time that's
what the libs do that's what the
leftists do we conservatives
we just we took the grill pill man we
just want to stay and grill and spend
time with our nice families often in the
suburbs and i work in politics
professionally this is my job and even i
think man can i just go home and grill
up my delicious good ranch or a steak
and you know have a nice drink and have
a good life
conservatives naturally don't want to do
don't feel the same burning fire to go
out and wield political power and so
that that is a dispositional issue but
you're so right it's not we are not
simply governed by letters on a page of
a statute
it's against the u.s code it's against
federal law to protest in front of a
judge's house to influence a case it
went on for weeks after the leak from
the dobbs decision the cops didn't do
nothing the authorities didn't do
nothing even though you had a republican
governor in virginia presumably you had
uh federal law enforcement that is
supposed to enforce these laws and they
just they just don't do it you you saw
the the double standards during the the
vying insurrections of 2020 in 2021. you
had blm burned the country down for
eight months
usually the charges were dismissed in
some cases people were arrested and and
the current vice president the now vice
president raised money to bail those
people out of jail
meanwhile horn hat guy busts into the
capitol and cracks a coors light and
they throw those people into solitary
confinement and they practically throw
away the key so the law is not going to
enforce itself certainly not going to
enforce itself in a neutral way i agree
with all of that so how are we supposed
to get and wield power
yeah and that's really the the million
dollar question right is what do you do
now because what we're seeing so often
is the impotence of elected leaders even
somebody who might be more dedicated
like trump look at
like a executive order trump issues
versus an executive order that obama or
biden issues and the effectiveness of
those orders right trump issues an
executive order and his own generals his
own executive branch they just ignore
him they just completely move forward
with whatever they're doing and they
just hide it from the commander-in-chief
and they pay him no mind barack obama
issues the executive order about genders
and bathrooms and all of a sudden every
organization
in the country jumps to attention and
follows it as if he just issued some
kind of dictate including private
organizations not just government
organization
right and so you have to ask yourself as
an american conservative who believes in
the constitution and the letter of the
law both of these men have the same
elective office both these men operated
under the same rules both of these men
use the same instrument but they have
decidedly different impacts and
different effects why is that that's the
key question that you need to understand
and once you understand it you better
grasp where the power sits what you
start to realize is not all of our power
is simply in the branches as explained
to us it exists in things like media it
exists in things like our educational
institutions it exists in things like
non-government organizations it exists
in things like the permanent bureaucracy
that people call the deep state far more
power resides in those institutions than
resides in any one particular man who's
sitting in an office and so while
conservatives love to win elections and
love to think that one elected official
will step in and change those things
they need to understand that the rot is
far deeper it sits well into things like
the fbi things like our university
system and those are things that if
you're going to change things have to
fundamentally be rearranged possibly
dismantled and rebuilt if you're going
to see real change you can't simply just
stick someone into an elected office say
oh throw out all the bums and we'll get
them in the next election that doesn't
work and we've seen that time and time
again because when a republican is
president even a conservative republican
even a conservative republican with his
head pretty much screwed on straight
it is just a different thing than when a
democrat is president i sometimes think
of this when it comes to the media
because when i see anonymous reports in
nbc or the new york times washington
post about a republican president i
usually dismiss them
when i see anonymous sourcing in a
report in nbc and new york times in
washington post about a democrat
president i'm not so quick to dismiss
them i take them much more seriously is
this because i'm a hypocrite and i just
want to believe whatever is good for my
side and harmful to the other side i
don't think so
the reason
at least the way that i think about it
is that
they're different things when the
left-wing media is going after the
right-wing president that is to be
expected when the left-wing media are
going after the left-wing president
that's a totally different relationship
their access to those sources is way
better it's way more reliable the
incentives are completely different and
so even though it looks like it's the
same thing because the people are
different because the movements inside
of those power structures are different
the the way to to understand them is
different as well
yeah there's this guy antonio gramsci
and he was a marxist and he
wanted a revolution like the one that he
had seen in russia but he couldn't get
it going he ended up writing a lot in a
prison in italy i always say this was
mussolini's worst thing that mussolini
ever did maybe not the worst thing but
it was up there he put he put that man
in prison and not because he didn't
deserve it but then it focused gramsci's
mind and the god all of the guys
contributions to philosophy come out of
him sitting in prison
exactly so you're familiar with the fact
that basically gramsci said we're not
going to get a communist revolution in
kind of these western countries the way
we got in russia because they're too
affluent you can't create this deep
class divide the way you can in these
other countries and kind of get the
revolution going so what we need is is
this cultural hegemony right we're going
to march through the institutions most
people have probably heard the long
march of through the institutions right
and that's what's going to gain you
power in the west it's not the fault
line is not going to be
this class divide of rich versus poor
directly though it ends up spilling out
in that way in in in other uh
permutations but it's gonna be along
things like race and gender and these
other these other aspects of society
that allow them to create kind of these
fulcrums right there are a lot of people
who are willing to sign up for a
revolution that's going to put their
ideas first their priorities first and
subvert kind of the way that your your
society was uh was constructed before
that and so it is by grasping hold of
these different institutions that we
this these kind of ideologies have been
allowed to infiltrate and a lot of what
we're seeing has been sitting around for
a very long time a lot of people
especially kind of these idw you know
classical liberal type folks love to
think that wokeness is just some kind of
descendant it's it's you know
progressive and just went a little too
far it went off the rails and if we can
just dial things back 10 years if we can
roll liberalism back to the last patch
then things will be fine what they don't
realize is that wokeness is in many ways
like a direct decision of things like
the civil rights act and so this
ideology has been built into our system
for a very long time and its
implications are simply being felt full
force many many decades after it's been
deeply seeded through pretty much every
aspect of our society you're saying some
uh conversation about that now i'm
reminded of chris caldwell's book age of
entitlement came out a few years ago so
you're you're starting to see a little
bit of this discussion of huh maybe
wokeness isn't just the last five years
maybe actually this has deeper roots so
okay we've talked about gramsci we've
talked about cultural hegemony we've
talked about all of these things that
are very important from a 30 000 foot
view now for people who are listening
before i let you go people are listening
right now they're saying what do i do in
the year of our lord 2022 what do i do
as i look ahead there's going to be
presidential election in 2024. what do i
do as i look past that what tangibly
would you encourage conservatives to do
yeah again this is a really difficult
question first and foremost because
iranians may not like me for this but
i'm not a big fan of democracy
but i i i don't think that it works very
well and what we have is a fundamentally
democratic problem one of the issues
that conservatives have is they buy into
this myths of kind of like popular
action right that that if you get enough
people together because we see the left
do this right they get a bunch of
protesters together they stand outside
stuff they chant they yell they scream
things change and we think to ourselves
that's how things get done right that's
how that happens but as we talked about
we see a very different reaction from
when a leftist mob shows up to one thing
and then when some right wing protesters
showed up right left-wing mobs they have
the the sanction of the state they have
the sanction of the media they get away
with everything they have you know the
vice president bailing them out of jail
right wing people show up and they sit
in basically black sites you know
getting uh you know getting denied food
and sleep for for in medical care right
so we do not sit in kind of this even
play field where the left can you know
and the right both can use this popular
will to drive things whether we like it
or not not society is always ruled by an
organized minority right it is actually
our elites that dictate in large ways
what happens in our country they always
need a connection to kind of the popular
consciousness and the zeitgeist and the
support of the people but we need to
start understanding and focusing on the
fact that we need a better class of
leaders we need a class of leaders that
is willing to step out there defend the
things that we want them to defend fight
for the things we need them to fight for
and have our well-being in mind not the
well-being of other nations or of their
own personal uh patronage uh you know
network personal enrichment or something
right right right and to be fair all
elites are going to do that that's
another thing that that kind of
conservatives need to understand is what
we want all elites will always serve
their own interests that will always be
true well we want our elites that are
aligned with our interests who whose
well-being is tied to the well-being of
the average american worker in the
average american family not to some
multinational corporation or some giant
ngo somewhere or some super pac right
and so in a lot of ways i think looking
at people like ron desantis right a lot
of people want ron desantis to run for
president and i understand why but i
think that's a mistake because what he's
doing is setting up a a kind of test run
for how
regional power can be uh created so
you're saying you're saying you would
rather desantis stay in florida and keep
building up that power base i i would i
would take 10 more desantises as
governors before i would take one
desantis as president because i think
that 10 more desantis's would have a far
larger impact on their individual states
and regions and their ability to change
the values and the structures and the
power bases and the things that exist
there
and also give us a model for how these
regional how federalism was actually
supposed to work right the idea that the
government shouldn't be able to push
down
vaccine mandates and masks mandates and
and educational mandates on every single
you know inch of the united states
that's not how our system is supposed to
operate and if we had more
people who were conscious of that and
willing to step out beyond kind of this
federal prison that most of these
regional powers have been placed in i
think that would be a far more effective
thing i think conservatives have a much
better chance of changing things on that
level that doesn't mean that things
don't need to happen at the national
level but if you're hoping to just like
shove desantis or trump into the white
house in 2024 and that will just
fundamentally change direction america
is going in i don't think you've been
paying atten attention to what's been
happening in america in the last few
decades that's that's a really great
point and you know you say somewhat
provocatively that you you're
distrustful of democracy worth
remembering that the founding fathers
themselves had a pretty healthy
skepticism of mob rule and democracy and
you know they uh constructed a system
that has since decayed and been
perverted and there have been all sorts
of problems over the ensuing centuries
but they created a system that was in
large part uh designed to reign in the
the popular passions and uh
but but to your point uh power has moved
around in in ways that have really not
been to the benefit of the country and
it's going to take a lot more than one
presidential election to fix that i
really i really love your point though
on we've got this governor he's the most
powerful governor most effective
governor i've seen so certainly that i
see around the country today what if we
what if we stopped playing the game that
the libs are handing us what if we start
saying what if we build up more of those
kinds of power centers what if the rules
aren't if the rules of the game aren't
working for us what if we change the
rules really great point or and where
can people find you
oh absolutely uh i've got a youtube
channel uh i've got a sub stack where i
put out different articles and uh and
podcasts and things so if people want to
find me there you can just look for oren
mcintyre i've got a twitter which is
where most people know me from and
there's a link tree there that can just
bring people to where all my work is on
all the different sites and that kind of
thing excellent oren thank you for
coming on the show i appreciate it
absolutely thank you so much for having
me i really enjoyed it
[Music]
[Music]